الصراع بين الصرب والالبان ليس بجديد فهو
جزء من الخلاف حول وضع كسوف والحالي والتي
اعلنت استقلالها قبل 15 عاما كوسوفو
سكانها من اصل البني وكانت في السابق
مقاطعه من صربيا قبل اعلان استقلالها عام
2008 رفضت صربيا الاعتراف بدوله كوسوفو
وما زالت تعتبرها جزءا من صربيا على رغم
من عدم وجود سيطره رسميه عليها فيما تنظر
الاكثريه الالبانيه الموجوده في كوسوفو
الى نيكوسوفو هي بلدهم ويتهمون صربيا
بالاحتلال والقمع يتطلع البان كوسوفو
مستقبلا الى الاتحاد مع البانيا المجاوره
ضمن دوله البانيا الكبرى تعترف نحو 100
دوله باستقلال كوسوفو بما في ذلك الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بينما ان حازت روسيا
والصين وخمس دول من الاتحاد الاوروبي الى
صربيا بالحديث عن هذه الازمه تلقى المصنف
الاول عالميا في التنس نوفاك جوكوفيتش
ردود فعل غاضبه جراء اتخاذه موقفا سياسيا
وابرازه خلال بطوله في فرنسا كتب
جيوغوفيتش على احدى عدسات الكاميرا لبطوله
التنس المقامه في باريس كتبا كوسوفو قلب
صربيا اوقف العنف الا ان النجم الصربي قال
انه يدرك ان الناس سيختلفون معه في
الرساله السياسيه التي كتبها على عدسات
الكاميرا لكنها قضيه يؤيدها كما قال
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات